大家好,我是对外经济贸易大学素质经济与法律创新中心的主任
对外经济贸易大学法学院教授许可
非常高兴有机会在这里和大家分享
个人信息匿名化制度与实践
这一个重大又极迫的
法律问题
那么今天啊
我跟大家从四个方面
讨论
个人信息匿名化的制度
那么首先呢
跟大家讲一讲
个人信息匿名化的
限制的困
个人信息匿名化制度由来已久
早在
网络安全法制定过程之中
就把个人信息匿名化制度欠入在
42条
那么该条规定啊
经过处理
无法识别特定个人
且不能复原的
除外
那么42条这条在法律上被称之为淡书
他的目的呀
就是
为
个人信息的
数字化的利用
提供一个途径
那么我们看42条的
前半句话
讲的是
不得泄漏篡改
毁损
其个人信息
未经同意
不得向他人提供个人信息
这些都是从保护的角度
对个人信息做了规定
那么第42条的淡书
又被称之为
大数据条款
其目的
就是为了缓和
个人信息保护的
颜柯
为了数字产业的发展
提供一个可行的途径
那么同样内容
出现在民法点的
1038条的淡书之中
到了个人信息保护法
制定的过程中啊
曾经有过争论
是否
把匿名化的个人信息
写入个人信息保护法
那么这里面在学界上和食物界上都有很多的观点
其中有观点认为
个人信息匿名化是一个非常
难以实现的目标
甚至有学者指出
个人信息匿名化是一个破碎的承诺
因此
有不少学者
反对
在个人信息保护法的制定过程中
把
个人信息的匿名化
放在
条文之中
以避免
这一条款的
不当的使用
但是
全国的那法公伟
仍然坚持
个人信息保护
与个人信息利用的
基本原则
将
个人信息匿名化制度明确的
规定在了第四条
和第
第四条第四项里面
其立法目标呀
是遭然弱街的
那就是
通过匿名化制度
促进
个人信息
以及
负载个人信息的
数据
得到有效的利用
尽管呀
我们看到从
网络安全法
到个人信息保护法
都是图为个人信息
匿名化制度
建立一个制度上的框架
但遗憾的是呢
在实践中
这么一个被称之为大数据规则大数据条款的
制度啊
并没有
发挥作用
而是
明春时王
成为春儿不用的
僵尸条款
那么我们看看
这个功耗上的
数据
合规人的
治安时刻
那么到底什么叫做个人信息匿名化
能不能
不用遵照
个人信息保护法的
单独同意的要求
把它给出去
成为啊
大家关注的热点问题
甚至被称之为
治安时刻
那么
为了解决这个问题
我们的
行业专家
发挥了
积极的作用
那么通过制定一些团体标准
包括呀
互联网广告
匿名化实止难
以及呀
刚刚成立的
国家
数标委
去建立一套
数据流通的
匿名化实施指南
以及数据流通的
匿名化
效果评估方法的标准
都在为个人信息匿名化
建立一个可行的
操作指引
但依然很遗憾
这些团体标准
有的呢
尚未正式的发布
有的即使发布了
也没有成为
监管机构
和我们的
法院
广泛使用的
操作指南
那么由此啊
我们
可以进一步的去探讨
为什么
有了
我们的网络安全法
有了个人信息保护法
但却没有
真正的解决
个人信息匿名化的困境呢
那么我这里面呀
给大家
列出
几个理由
那么第一个理由
那就是
个人信息匿名化的边界
难以接近
匿名化信息和个人信息的核心差异啊
在于可实别性
但可实别永远不是一个非黑记牌
可实别永远是一个连续的光谱
他不只有黑白二色
而是在从黑
到白的过程中有大量的灰色区域
那么到底
这些
灰色区域的
个人信息
他俗不属于匿名化信息
存在的广泛真理
那么第二个
实践中的困难是
个人信息保护法
对于匿名化的条款呀
非常之简单
他实际上是两个标准
一个标准是
无法识别
第二个标准是
不可复原
但无法识别和不款复原的
判断的主题
判断的方式
判断的手段
都语言不详
缺乏具体的解释
和操作职业
这也是法律
作为一个抽象规则
说不可避免的出现的
实施的困难
第三个
欠缺控制剩余风险的制度
在个人信息保护法之间过程之中
已经有大量的业界的专家反映
个人信息匿名化制度
在理论上
是存在的
在这现实中
几乎不可能
因为永远有着剩余风险的存在
大家经常举的例子
实际上就是谷歌的
公开了
匿名化个人信息的例子
在那个例子之中
谷歌
把已经匿名化的信息公之于众
但是很快的
这些信息都被重新的识别
到特定的自然
那么由此
学界逐渐形成公司
个人信息的匿名化
不可能是绝对的
也不可能
没有任何的
残余的风险
但是我的个人信息保护法
并没有针对
个人信息匿名化之后的残余风险
剩余风险
做出规定
那么由此引发了社会公众
和监管部门的担忧
那么如何化解
个人信息匿名化之后的不可控的剩余风险
那么成为啊
我们个人信息匿名化实施的一个
关键性的问题
第四个
个人信息匿名化在技术上
和去标识化呀
是相互混淆的
我估计的个人信息保护法
非常清楚的区分了匿名化
和去标识化两种制度
匿名化之后的个人信息
不属于个人信息
无需遵守
个人信息保护法
对于个人信息的一系列的监管要求
而去标识化的个人信息
仍然属于个人信息
个人信息保护法
并没有针对去标识化的个人信息
作出单独的规定
而是将去标识化
界定为
个人信息处理者
降低
个人信息识别
风险的
一种风险管控措施
这两种在法律上
竟然分明的
二分法
在实践中
却面临着一个尴尬的现实
那就是
大量的
个人信息匿名化技术
和去标识化的技术
往往是一样的
那么
当
其
采取去标识化的方法
进行匿名化的时候
那么由此而来的问题是
到底
它是一个
去标识化
还是一个
匿名化呢
正是因为上上种种的原因啊
个人信息匿名化条款
尽管
在法律上
早已存在
但是呢
存而不用
尤其是
当代
随着
人工智能大数据的发展
数据的交易流通
数据要输市场建构
数据的反复利用
迫在没几
但是因为
大量流通的
数据
是承载着
个人信息的更数据
如果没有办法破解
个人信息匿名化制度
就不太可能
形成一个
高效流通的
数据要输市场
那么
在这个背景下呀
我们讲
个人信息匿名化
一定要
在实践中得到解决
那么个人信息匿名化
其实呀
它并不只是中国一个国家
所面临的问题
在全球范围
个人信息匿名化制度
始终
处于
各国家个人信息保护法
立法的
重点和难点问题
不同的国家
处于不同的监管考量
根据自己的
立法的
原理
和目标
其实采取了
不尽相同的
个人信息匿名化的实践
那么我们大致可以从两个维度
去观察
全球的经验
第一个维度是
由谁
去判断
个人信息
是否
进行的匿名化
那么根据足体的标准
可以分成
这四种不同的方案
第一个方案
是欧盟方案
它是最为严格的方案
他要求
如果世界上任何一个人
不能从
信息中识别出特定个人
则为匿名信息
那么这句话反过来理解就是
世界上如果有一个人能够识别
特定个人
他就不是
匿名化信息
这是最为严格的
匿名标准
那么第二个
方案是
英国和新加坡
所创设的
有动机入侵者的标准
那么这里面的有动机入侵者
指的并不是世界上任何一个人
而是
那些具备了
合理能力
能够适用
适当的资源
进行调查的人
那里面这里面的人
一般来说
我们讲的就是一个
社会公众
首先他不是一个专业人士
不要求是个专家
其次呀
他不要求
这个人
具备先前的知识
比如说
我和
毛甲
是朋友
我知道他有一个特殊的文生
在网上流传了一个照片
我看到了这个地方有特殊的文生
那么我由此判断
照片
里面的人啊
就是毛甲
但问题是
一般公众
是不可能了解
毛甲
具有这一个
身体特征的
尽管我可以去识别到这个信息
但是呢
因为我动用了之前的
知识和信息啊
所以
我不符合这里面的
有动机入侵者的要求
那么产生的国家主要是英国和新加坡
第三个方案
指的是提供方的标准
这里面特别
出现在数据流通的场景下
当数据从
数据的提供者
流向
数据的接收方的时候
如果
对于数据的提供方而言
能够识别出特定信息
那么他就是一个
非匿名化信息
如果不能识别呢
他就是一个匿名化信息
那么与日本相对应的是美国的
接收方的标准
那么美国的接收方的标准要求
如果信息在接收方
和提供方之间进行了流动
只有
数据的接收方
不能识别特定个人的
那么他就是一种匿名化信息
我可以举一个简单的例子
假设
我把我的学校的
公盘
交给了
我的朋友
这个不公盘上没有姓名
没有照片
他只有学校的名称
以及我的
单位的号码
假设我单位号码是001
那么对于接收方来说
他
不太可能
从
卡片上的数字
识别出特定个人
尽管我是知道特定的个人是谁了
那么在这个情况下
我们认为
对于接收方来说
他获得的就是一个匿名信息
这么一种接收方标准
是对于产业
和数据流通来说
最友好的标准
那么这个典型的
国家
就是美国
而且我们现在非常
新写的看到
在欧盟的最新的案例中
使用了
这个接收方标准
从而改变了
欧盟GDPR
所强调的
任何人的标准
我们来看一看这个案子
这个最新的案例
就是欧盟数据保护监督机构
EGPS
树
欧洲单一清算委员会
SRB的案子
这个案子非常简单
SRB
把关于个人的评论
传输给外部评估机构得勤
那么对于这么一种
数据的传输
是不是违反了
个人信息保护法中的
个人的同意
以及告知的
这些内容呢
欧盟的
EGPS
认为
警管
SRB
采取了一些假名化的措施
这些传输的
数据
仍然属于
个人数据
所以判定了
SRB
违法
那么2023年4月26号
普通法院
并没有支持
欧盟数据保护监督机构的
判断
而是认为
传输给德琴的数据
属于
匿名化的
个人数据
那么对于这么一个判决
EGPS不符
上述到欧盟法院
要求重新做出裁决
那么经过了
两年的审理
最近
欧盟法院做出了终审的判决
那么这个判决之所以重要
就是因为他处理了
匿名化的标准问题
那么首先
法院
重申了
个人数据包括了主观的意见评价和评论
也就是说他不只是事实的呈现
也包括了主观的评估
主观的意见
所以在这个案件之中
SRB
向第三方
德琴
传输的个人数据
属于
个人数据的概念
那么这里面
第二个问题就是
假名化不等于匿名
对于
SRB所主张的
采取了假名化的措施
所以他就是匿名化的一种主张
法院并没有认可
那么法院讲的是
在风险识别上
在判断标准上
要回到可识别性
是否构成个人数据
不能只看采取了拿写技术或措施
而是
要看
根本上他是否对于主体来说是可识别的
那么以下是法院这一次最大的创新点
它的创新点是区分了两种不同的视角
首先是数据控制者
也就是我们国家所讨论的
个人信息处理者的视角
假名后的评论依然属于个人数据
因为控制者仍然保留着附加信息或密钥
可以与特定的个人重新管理
但是
对于接受方来说
如果计数个措施有效阻断了合理条件下的再识别
那么
对于接受方而言
这些数据就不构成了个人数据
换言之
它就是一种匿名化之后的数据
那么这么一个
判决的结果
可以说
在根本上改变了我们讲的
匿名化数据和假名化数据的认定方法
终结了绝对化的匿名
而是采取了一个动态的
强调场景的匿名
好
那么刚才谈到的是识别的主体
所以我们可以看到
从全球的范围之内
欧盟有一个重大的转向
从我们讲的任何一个人
转向了数据的接受方
然后我们再来看行为标准
行为标准所解决的问题是
到底多大程度上
识别和多大程度上
复原
那么
刚才我们讲过
在技术大开的眼中
几乎任何经过匿名化的信息只要采取
所有的穷尽所有的可能
就有
那么几率
重新识别到特定个人
那么对于这个问题
不同国家采取了不同的标准
有的标准是一般人标准
有的标准是高度可行的标准
有的标准是合理的可能的标准
那么从法律的角度来说
有一句法宴
叫做法律不强人所难
法律永远采取的是一般人的标准
或者说
合理可能的标准
而不太可能要穷尽所有的方式和方法
举个例子
我们说大海劳增
在理论上是可行的
只要我们不惜人力物力
不惜成本
就能在大海中找到
我们丢在大海里面的那根针
但是在法律上
不会认为大海劳增是一种合理的可能
因为他的成本远远超过了他的收益
所以法律上讲的可能性
一般都是合理的可能的
那么以上
我跟大家简单的回顾了全球
对于个人心情匿名化的
基本的一些进展
那么回到第三部分
个人心情匿名化
在我国该怎么去完善
怎么去实施
在第一部分
我跟大家讲了个人心情匿名化
有着这样那样的困境
那么究其实质
个人心情匿名化实际上
他有着三重的担心
这三重担心导致了各方
对于个人心情匿名化
他尽管一致的认可
但是在实践中落实下来
非常困难
第一个担心
是个人信息处理者的担心
他既担心个人心情匿名化措施
无法达到法律要求
我做了白做
也担心了
如果我遵守了
一些团体标准
行业标准
那又使得匿名的
信息
太多上市的利用价值
第二个担心是监管结构的担心
监管结构担心匿名化成为
个人信息处理者规避监管的工具
我国的监管部门
将个人信息保护
谋定在个人信息
这么一种法律的概念之上
如果通过匿名化
把信息
变为非个人信息
那么所有的监管的手段
都上市了抓手
所以监管结构
特别担心
企业
滥用
匿名化措施
导致监管目的落空
那用户其实也担心
那就是说呀到底的匿名化是不是真的
你所谓的匿名化有没有
实现保护我个人的目标
那么面对这三重的担心呀
我们主张采取一种
从结果匿名
到过程匿名的方案
通过一系列的
程序性的设定
去解决这三重担心
那么第一重担心
是我们讲的个人信息处理者
往往是企业的担心
企业担心啊
我做了很多个人信息匿名的工作
但是呢
不认可
那么我做的工作
图征成本而没有带来好处
那么怎么解决
我们提出的方案是
建议一套事前的推定匿名的制度
也就是说
只要个人信息处理者
证明了采取的合格的匿名
化的技术设计
就应该推定匿名化有效
那么这么一种推定有效
实际上就是让数据
和个人信息先跑起来
不要一开始呀
就为手为尾
不敢流动
解决了
大家不敢供给数据
不敢接收数据的担心
但是
推定匿名
仍然不是最终匿名
还要看
他有没有达到法律上的标准
这就是刚才我们讲的
欧盟法院
他也指出
采取的假名化或匿名化的措施
不足以证明
他就是匿名化和假名化的数据
所以这里面
要有一个事后的判定匿名
那么这麽能事后的判定匿名
解决的谁的担心呢
他解决的是
监管机构的担心
监管机构
把握着
最后能否认定匿名的这么一个
大门
他如果觉得
你尽管采取了
事前的匿名化技术
但并不能最终的在法律上证明
他就是匿名化的
你仍然要承担相应的责任
但是我们也要指出
事后的判定匿名
并不是随机的
任意的发动的
他需要有法定的程序
从而有效的平衡了市场上
积极的推动匿名化技术的发展
和监管机构去控制
匿名化标准的
这么两个难题
最后
面对着广泛存在的剩余的风险
我们需要一个系统的合规的匿名
匿名化并不是万事大吉
匿名化之后的个人信息
并不是一点风险
没有的个人信息
那么对于这些难以穷尽的风险
我们需要个人信息处理着
全面的履行合规义务
尽可能降低剩余风险的残留
最大程度的保护个人的权益
那么这就是我们称之为同心员结构
同心员结构分别对应着不同的
主体的担心
事先推定匿名
对应的是个人信息处理者
让个人信息处理者
勇于尝试匿名化技术
推动数据流动
事后判定匿名
对应者的是监管机构的担心
防范
企业
滥用
匿名化技术造成监管的空白
最后一个是解决的是个人的担心
最大程度的保护个人
在匿名化过程之中的权益
不会受到侵害
那么
我们简单的跟大家讲一讲
同心员的三个部分
第一个
事前的推定匿名
那么可以采取一些标准化的设计
通过一些差分隐私的技术
那么至于这里面讨论到的技术路径
仍然有赖于后续
通过我们的行业标准
最佳实践与落实
那么这么一种推定的效力
它可以使得处理者
在证明自己采取了国家标准
或者说最佳实践之后
无需承担后续的举动责任
为市场主体划定横线
促进数级要求市场的发展
同心员的第二部分
是事后的判定匿名
刚才我们讲
事后的判定匿名
不能是一个随意的发动的过程
它的触发条件
往往发生在
合理怀疑
事前推定的匿名
失效的场景
而且这种失效的场景
可能已经造成了不良影响
包括引发了一些
个人或者是
个人信息处理者的一些关注
这种情况下
无论是监管机构
还是法院
都应当基于法律
而不是基于刚才我们所说的
行业标准
最佳实践作出判断
那么这里面
最重要的问题是
如何在法律上
将个人信息匿名化的两个标准
无法识别和不能复原
进一步的明确
那么
从数据流通的角度
我们认为应当
顺应全球个人信息
匿名化制度的发展趋势
站在
接收方的角度
去判断
个人信息
是不是
能够复原
无法识别
那么在识别方式上
应当是合理的进行
识别
而不是采取所有可能的手段
那么这么一种
判定的标准
于我们现在最新的标准
个人信息匿名化
处理指南
及评价办法
是一致的
那么根据这一个办法
我们可以看到
这里面的无法识别
就指的是
数据接收方在限定场景和设定风险
环境之下
数据不可识别特定自然
所以我们可以看到
它核心的一个点就是
数据接收方作为判断标准
那么对于不能复原
它也强调了
是一个合理的技术和资源
而且
这里面的复原和识别
它们的对象是不同的
识别指的是特定自然人
而复原指的是特定的
个人的信息
我们举一个最简单的例子
假设
我们把
某人的
身份证号码
做了一个研码的处理
这是非常简单的一个假名化技术
那么对于
接收到这一个经过研码之后的
身份证号码的人来说
他如果接合其他的信息
比如说
第二号码
把这个人重新找到了
那么他就不符合
无法识别的要求
但是
他尽管把这个人重新找到
他仍然不能
去把这个身份证号码
不足
他知道这个人叫张三
但他仍然不知道这个人的身份证号码
空缺的这几位到底什么
那么我们称之为
不能复原
那么匿名化要求两个条件
同时的具备才能构成
匿名化
那么有一个不具备
就不能实现匿名化的结果
那么刚才们举个例子
那显然
他就是一种我们讲的
非匿名化的结果
或者反过来
他没有办法识别到张三这个人
但是他把他身份证号码进行了复原
那么我们也认为
他不构成匿名化
最后一个
是系统的
格归匿名
系统合约匿名的
重心
是保护个人
所以这里面首当其冲的是
告诉个人
匿名化的
目击方式
也就是说
在我们的影视政策
个人信息处理规范里面
应当将
是否进行匿名
告诉个人
我们不能因为匿名化制度
将个人信息变成了非个人信息
就对个人
采取一个
不告知的方法
那么这个实际上就是
刚才我们看到的欧盟的
案例
他尽管他认可了
向第三方传输的
并不是个人信息
他仍然要求
数据的控制者
向个人
与行告知义务
那么这里面我们要求
我们的
个人信息处理者
在进行匿名化的之前
要告诉个人
那么除了告诉
个人这么一个告知义务以外
还有两个重要的
程序性的要求
第一个
匿名化的评价
第二个是
个人信息保护的
评估
那么
匿名化评价
个人信息保护评估
这两个其实是不同的
匿名化评价
评价的是匿名化的效果
个人信息保护
营养评估
评估的是对个人
影响的程度
那么
匿名化的评价方法
主要评价的维度
就是刚才我们所谈到的
无法识别
不能复原
以及技术上的
对抗性的测试
它是由组织内部的合规团队
或者是第三方
独立执行的
它的目标
去判断
我们刚才所谈到的
这么一种
事前的
系统性的匿名
能不能符合要求
如果符合要求
判断的通过
在系统合规匿名的
最后一部分
是关于禁止性的义务
特别是禁止再识别的义务
要采取有效措施
防止数据被重新识别
同时
禁止可能以个人造成重大影响的方式
去处理信息
保护个人信息权益
那么以上
就是我们来讨论到的
三重匿名的方法
分别对应者
个人信息处理者
监管机构和个人的
对于匿名化的担心
那么最后
我跟大家简单的
分享一下
两个个人信息匿名化的
典型案例
第一个案例
是大家都非常熟悉的
广告的案例
传统的户外广告以静态
方式为主
广告主难以实现精准的投放
那么为了解决这个问题
我们需要个性化广告
那么个性化广告就要求我们采取一个
数据融合的方法
对于这么一种数据融合
如何去解决
其中所隐含的个人信息保护的难题
那么通过我们讲的
匿名化制度
就是一个重要的
技术解决方案
那么我们可以看到
在
多方共同参与的
数据流通的场景中
包含了
广告主
户外的媒体方
和其他的数据的合作方
那么它进行流通的数据类型
包括了广告位的信息
广告主的订单的数据
互联网行为数据
位置支持库的数据
那么这里面
有很多属于个人的数据
那如何解决这个问题呢
还是回到刚才我们讲的
三个
同心源
首先就是采取一个合格的匿名化技术
那么这个合格的匿名化技术
主要就是
可信的数据空间
密文计算与隔离
以及统计化结果的输出
那么在这个三个要素里面
要注意
在一头一尾
化解了各方的担心
第一个
它把
数据进行了同态加密
采取了
差分隐私多方安全计算的方法
降低了个人信息
被重新识别的可能性
不仅如此
它里面加上一个非常重要的
可信的数据空间
那么在这个空间里面
由于没有更高维度的数据的接入
使得呀
将个人重新再识别
几乎不可能
最后
在输出的环节
呈现的是一个统计指标
不涉及到个人信息
那么有此我们发现
这么一种匿名化技术
解决了我们所担心的
个人信息
复原和再识别的难题
于是同时为了进一步的去降低剩余风险
相关的
参与主体采取了访问控制与权限管理
审计和溯源
合同约束和用途限定的种种的方法
降低了剩余风险
那么由此呢
我们谈到的三重
不从
机制
技术机制
法律机制
和后续的合规管理机制
都得到满足
那么
事前的匿名事后的可验证剩余风险可控
使得
个人信息保护和商业利益呀
得到了
同等的重视
得到了平衡
那么第二个
典型案例
是当前大家讨论也非常多的医疗领域的
匿名化的案子
那么我们都知道
最值钱的
个人信息
其实啊
就是我们的
医疗信息
但也正是因为如此
在流通中也面临着重大的
法律上的困难
如何更好地保护
个人的隐私
个人的
对于敏感
信息的
担心
那么由此成为我们讲的
医疗领域个人信息个人数据流动的大难题
那么在这个
场景下我们可以看到
主要采取的方式
就是
开密名的模型和专家组的
审批机制
这是一个
我们看到的关于
胸部CQ的数据的立民化处理
那么在这里面有着
两个数据的主体
一个是医院
一个呢
就是我们所说的
医疗器械的赏伤
这里面存在的潜在的风险
当然是对于个人信息
尤其是个人敏感信息
带来的风险
那么为了解决这个问题
采取了开密名的方法
这个开等于5
采取了去标识的方法
那么
在
技术的方案实施之后
这里面最重要的方法
就是我们讲的
一个
医民化的效果的评价
通过专家组
去评价
医民效果
来去解决
可能的风险问题
那么
在
合规保障
管理措施
和
技术方案三轨
旗下的
作用下呢
这个案例
实现了
可用不可实
不可复原的目标
提供了可复制的
医疗影响数据
医民化的流程
为行业的隐私保护
提供了示范
那么
今天啊
我们花了
比较短的时间
和大家交流了
个人信息医民化制度的来龙去脉
分析了
全球范围之内
围绕着个人信息医民化的一些经验
和最新进展
提出了
个人信息医民化的
三个
前后相继的
制度的实践
最后啊
跟大家分享了两个案例
我想呢
个人信息医民化制度
关乎着
中国
数据要素市场发展的大局
是实现个人信息价值
和保护个人信息权益
最重要的
苏宁
那么对于这个问题呢
远远
还没有
彻底解决的时候
我们期待着
各位同仁
能够从技术
法律
产业
三个维度
探索
个人信息医民化制度的
破局之路
那么这里面
我给大家提供了我之前
完成了
两个工作
一篇是学书诺文
一篇是我们和
蚂蚁研究院
一起发布的个人信息医民化制度的卖币书
也期待大家能够多多的批评指证
好
以上呢
就是我今天和大家分享的主要内容
也期待着后续能有更多的机会和大家交流
学习
今天的分享到此为止
谢谢大家